Vous admirerez son travail
parce que reproduire des radios à la main,
en plus à la bombe,
est extrêmement difficile.
Mais bon, il s'agit d'un artiste de rue,
et il se trouve qu'il est également diplômé en chimie appliquée.
Nychos, artiste de rue autrichien,
pousse à son plus haut niveau l'expression « vue éclatée »,
en éclaboussant de dissections humaines et animales les murs à travers le monde.
Influencé par les bandes dessinées et le heavy metal,
Nychos insuffle une énergie jeune et séduisante à l'anatomie,
j'adore ça.
Les artistes de rue pensent aussi que l'art appartient au public.
Si cette anatomie de rue est à ce point captivante,
c'est parce qu'elle est tellement éloignée du monde médical.
Elle vous force à la regarder,
à y confronter vos propres perceptions de l'anatomie,
que vous la trouviez belle,
dégueulasse,
morbide,
ou impressionnante, comme moi.
Rien que le fait qu'elle suscite ces réactions
vient de notre relation intime et souvent changeante avec elle.
Tous les artistes présentés aujourd'hui
sont partis d'illustrations médicales pour leur art.
Mais pour eux,
l'anatomie n'est pas quelque chose à mémoriser,
mais plutôt comme la base pour vraiment comprendre le corps humain ;
pour la dépeindre de façon accessible,
à travers la bande dessinée,
la peinture corporelle
ou l'art de rue.
L'art anatomique a le pouvoir
de transcender les pages d'un manuel médical,
de susciter l'intérêt du public,
de réinjecter de l'enthousiasme pour le monde médical,
en connectant notre Moi le plus profond avec notre corps à travers l'art.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)